(audience cheering)
- Hi.
- You always look so rock and roll.
Oh my god wait, do you
have a, a pet with you?
- Yeah, my dog is.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
You know, It's really,
I just had dog hair is like
the last part of the outfit.
It's what I put on right before I go out.
- I love it. You came out
and I was like, oh my God,
you look like me at home.
I was like, this is like,
definitely like a dog or something.
- This is like a lesbian status symbol.
(Kelly and audience laughs)
Like the more
pet hair that you have on
your body, the hotter you are.
- [Kelly] Yeah. You love animals.
- I love animals.
- [Kelly] What's your dog's
name again?
- Her name is Luchia Katrina Lualer.
- That is quite a name.
- Yes, she's very, she's
gonna be a figure skater.
And an opera singer, she's very talented.
- Big Dreams. Big dreams.
Just leaving her place ever.
I love it. I Love it.
- You know, it's really like,
And then I have three cats.
So there's cat hair,
- [Kelly] Oh do they-
get along,
- there's dog hair.
- [Kelly] with the dog?
- It's a really great, exciting family.
Except sometimes Luchia will hump the cats
and the cats don't understand.
I think they wanna feel, like, in control.
I don't know. Like when I hump something
(audience and Kelly laughs)
I don't feel like
in control necessarily.
- Well, I think you're doing it wrong.
- Maybe I, I don't know.
Maybe I need to, I need more practice.
- Okay. Well, things to do.
You can only get better with practice.
So, love this. There's no segue.
So it's almost Halloween.
So do you get many trick or treaters?
Are you really into it?
- I have never gotten any
trick or treaters. And so-
- Is your house that scary or.
- It's kind of like a little bit far in
so it's a little, it's hard to get to.
You know what, I have coyotes.
- Oh. Yeah, well that's not exciting.
- Yeah. I have coyotes and
snakes and there was the the big-
Look at this. I mean, it's beautiful.
- [Kelly] It's beautiful.
- [Margaret] It's beautiful,
- [Kelly] Its ears, yeah.
- [Margaret] but it's also-
And that's the snake. That snake.
I couldn't even see the back.
That snake was almost
eight feet long and it's,
- That's in your backyard?
- That was in my backyard.
And I, asked animal
control and they said, Oh
oh, it's a gopher snake
and it'll eat rats and then
keep moving and it eats
rattlesnakes. So-
(crowd gasps)
- You know what, I
actually all of a sudden,
like this snake. Yeah.
- [Margaret] It's actually
good snake to have
- I have a huge rat problem.
- Yeah. It's good to, cause
it'll eat all of the problems.
So maybe we could- it'll-
- And it doesn't attack
you. Like your (indistinct)
- I think that what it'll
do if it's frightened
it will mimic a
rattlesnakes movements. But-
- And that is going to get it killed.
- How would you not know it's a rattle-
but it doesn't have a rattle.
It doesn't, it doesn't hurt people.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- It's actually a good snake to-
I'm like I guess there's a good snake.
I saw this-
- You should name it.
- I should name it.
But I saw the skin and I
thought somebody had taken
off their pantyhose in my yard,
(audience and Kelly laughs)
- and I'm like,
- Just shed it.
- What in the Rockettes.
What kind of dancer took off
their pantyhose in my yard?
'Cause it was long, long legs.
- Yeah, what kind of
party were they having?
- I mean, somebody put their pantyhose,
without a control top even.
- How dare you.
- How dare you
- Rude
- Bragging
that you don't need a control top
or reinforced toe in my yard.
And it was actually this,
- Reinforced toe.
- It was the skin
of that snake. I'm like girl,
just leave your skin here.
- My kids would be so excited
and then terrified and I don't
know if they'd go outside.
So that was a look
at the standup tour that
you're doing right now.
So. How's it going?
- It's really great.
I loved going on tour.
I love being able to,
I think be in a place,
with other people.
This is like an incredible thing.
You know, we're like
actually going to shows
and audiences are really excited.
You know, you are really excited.
So there's a kind of magic
happening in live performance,
that I think I didn't realize how much
I would miss it and I'm
so happy to be back at it.
- Yeah. We're like so appreciative of it.
- So appreciative.
- I've been to way more shows like
in the past year then I have in years.
'Cause you're like, wait,
it might get taken away.
- Yeah. It feels like
something that is so like huge.
So there's, there's a real excitement
and electricity around it that,
I'm really hanging onto that.
I think what is really
important after all the things
that have happened is to
have and nurture that sense
of gratitude.
So I'm grateful for the snake.
I'm grateful for the coyote.
I mean, you know, within reason.
But it's really, it's really
important to be grateful
for live performance because
it's something that we missed
For so long, so.
- Or even this, I was doing zoom forever
like having people back on stage.
- It's nice
- It's fun.
- It is nice
- Yeah. But also we do
miss not wearing pants.
Let's be real.
So you're also in "The L Word".
So what made you wanna
be a part of that show?
- Well, I have been
obsessed with the show since
the first L word.
And I would get so excited
when I would play, do shows
in Vancouver because the
cast would come see me.
And it was just so, it's
like, ooh, it's Shane.
You know?
It's so excited to see
the people from the show
that you love.
So I was thrilled to be back.
And so it's the new generation
and in the new show.
So I'm really thrilled.
I think it's gonna be really fun to watch.
And it's wild to be in
a show that you watch
because then you feel like,
like, oh wow, this is all very
magical. So.
- And then you feel almost
like a child 'cause you're like
these aren't, they're
not the real character.
They're real people just playing.
- Right.
- Yeah.
But I get like nerdy about it.
I like call them by their character name.
- Yeah, you know, I do too.
Like why not?
Like I think it's a really,
it's a beautiful experience.
It's one of the beautiful parts
of show business where you can feel like
oh these spaces are
definitely real in a way.
And also fake in a way.
So it's really, it's a
really fun way to play.
- Yeah. And it, I think it keeps it
like the youth about it too.
'cause you get still
excited about it, you know?
You're not jaded about, I love that.
So who are some of your
LGBTQ role models growing up?
- I think Billy Jean
King, Martina Navratilova.
- [Kelly] Sports, (indistinct) yeah.
- Yeah. Because their genius and their
their exceptional talent is,
it's unassailable, you know
they are absolutely at
the top of their game.
So powerful. And it cannot be questioned.
Like Brittney Griner, her
excellence cannot be questioned.
You know, we need these
incredible athletes here.
We need them in our country, in our world.
And we need to idolize them
because it's like they're
I know they're unmatched, you know,
So it's whats I love.
- It's awesome too,
like with athletes, I'm always like, geez
I guess that's what we're capable of.
Like, I'm never gonna know
cause I'm not working that hard.
But you watch them and you're like, God
that's the human body is
capable of amazing things.
- It's Incredible. I mean,
I can't even walk a couple of blocks so.
- Without like a deep breath, do you mean.
- Without like hats every-
deet covered in deet
No, I'm really like
impressed by the courage.
Especially in such any
sort of like male dominated
field like sports. You
know, when women can excel
and queer women.
- [Kelly] It's cool for little
girls to see that too. Yeah.
- [Kelly] It's beautiful-
- Yeah. It's powerful,
- [Kelly] To see that. Yeah.
- I love it.
- Well, your parents owned a bookstore
for the LGBTQ community in San Francisco.
That's awesome. You must
have had so much support.
Like growing up was that
really cool to have all that.
- It was really incredible.
And also to be able to
witness the very beginnings
of queer politics in my life.
To see the extent of Harvey Milk's reach.
You know, the people
that worked for my father
were very influenced by Harvey Milk,
and the devastation of his
assassination followed by
The real trauma of AIDS, you
know, and to see the community
from there rise up again
into what we are now.
It's really powerful.
So to be able to be a part
of gay history in that way.
My first gay pride was 1978, so.
- Were you little.
- Yeah. It's really
amazing to have been raised
up in a community that really thrives.
- It's so rare and such a blessing.
You know what I'm saying?
Like, not everybody gets
that kind of upbringing.
Like, especially where I'm from.
People have to hide themselves.
Like how, how amazing that
you, you know, were empowered
at such a young age to really be yourself.
That's incredible.
- It's really, incredible.
- I want all families to
be like that, you know,
embrace who we are.
- All families should
be like that. Because queerness is real.
It's not any kind of fault or affliction.
It's just an, it's just
a part of who we are.
It's just another way to be.
And so when, when we can
accept that and celebrate that.
We are so, we're doing
such a service to everyone.
- Yeah. Whole community works.
Yeah. Well we need to
do a commercial break.
Be sure to go online for tickets
to Margaret Cho's standup
tour and look for her
in "The L word: Generation Q".
The season Premiere drops
on Showtime, November 18.